hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ich habe hier in
meiner hand eine oculus wir haben
nämlich voll auf dieses zugeschickt
bekommen großes aber dafür dankeschön
lang ihr nicht auch ein schönes hinter
der kamera
denn ich mache erst zusammen mit luca 1
auch viele special und sein ein spiel wo
man lockerer und anspielungen roboter
den ball an muss also alles in allem
höchst wahrscheinlich selber wollte
bio ist friedlich heute schreiben stehen
ich habe kein geld von abschluss
bekommen sondern einfach nur die brille
damit ich dir liebe und die liebe damit
videos mag ich die brille jetzt mal auf
und dann sehe ich schon wie rechts ab ok
so das ding ist virtual reality
megastadt ich habe schon auf getestet
luca macht das heute mal ersten mal
durch gärten abspielen die man sich
schon sehr geil wenn so ein staat nicht
die musik höre ich bin jetzt gerade in
diesem winter nach dem der roboter
werkstatt und ich kann jetzt nicht
einfach hier
die in roboter nehmen schlagen ich
kannte ihn rauszunehmen und die zum
beispiel einfach den kopf arbeiten wo es
gerade gesehen bekannten rechnen
ihr wert diesen arm auf locker gemacht
dann gehe ich jetzt einfach mal raus war
und fragt mal ersten mal ein paar gegner
das breite bürger zurück moretti
willkommen anmelden agent 34 abgesehen
spielend einfach position war okay
draußen agenturen ich hoffe wir fahren
nicht bei dir irgendwie machen
da kommen die walter
[Musik]
wir haben uns dann spontan entschieden
dafür das ganze bisherige nur als warm
werden zählen lassen bei luca sich etwa
auf wer musste weil das noch nie
gespielt hat und ab jetzt also was wir
gleich sehen werde zählt es richtig in
unser bett
oh mein gott oh mein gott
über viele die kommen von videos oder
schiff mal 3 2 1
[Musik]
die weiteren aber ich werde morgen
negative dafür noch 19 sekunden
wie möglich frei in dem auch einfach bei
seiner verfilmung mit dem konverter also
gemacht habe irgendwann wird
er bekommt
natürlich bedeuten wenn man das lied ich
habe auf jeden fall das ziel schon
geschafft da kommt jetzt an
wenn wir beim 28 da musste ich sogar
erst mal die grundlagen von der
virtuellen realität erklären und jetzt
gleich hier im moment wort zum
allerersten mal eine virtuelle welt
gesehen hat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich machen
august statt das ging so circa fünf
minuten weiter lockern aber relativ
schnell gelernt und am ende sogar echt
ein bisschen was drauf gehabt also war
wirklich bereit für das finale für die
challenge gehören die hohen tauern
rubrik ob ihre füllten vor gerufen ich
habe glaube ich sie vielleicht ein
gefährlicher werden freundlich kommt
die deutsche braust der luft werden
ich hatte voll
ja ich habe ich richtig erst gestellt
nach europa spiel damit einen kleinen
eklat das hatte auch bei seinem
allerersten wie a video nochmal ein
schnelleres für die richter ist eine
sache des kopfes man weiß nicht wie man
das auf gefestet damit den schaden an
der ganzen geschichte aber er hat
wahrscheinlich auch so ein spaß gewesen
die luft fliegen mit leichtigkeit
zerstört habe